a wizard is never late Frodo Baggins no
is he early he arrives precisely with
him in sheriff welcome to the December
2019 Journal that's right 2019 you
remember 2019 a lot of people might have
forgotten about it by now not me we're
still living there because this is my
journal slash vlog slash whatever you
want to call it for December the last
month of 2019 kind of the finale if you
will so I'm not gonna take up too much
of your time enjoy the happenings and
the goings on in my month of December
2019 as always we transition into the
events the HBO spawn series is also
great here we are
deep in the am and my review of the
Irishman goes live in the morning I'll
be honest with you there's something
about the review that feels kind of off
and I cannot put my finger on it I don't
know what it is I don't know if it's
because I kind of feel like I come
across as a bit preachy in the middle
when I start talking about how you can
break the movie up among multiple days
which is true but I don't know it feels
kind of off but in the end the the basis
the consensus of the review is I really
liked it and so that is true that's
accurate so I'm just gonna let it ride I
don't know what it is just playing
Mortal Kombat in ships he's just staring
at me what do you like doing a thing I'm
getting a haircut tomorrow anyhow as
Oscar season ramps up it's like from
Thanksgiving through the New Year there
are going to be a metric [ __ ] ton of
movies I just don't see they just slip
through the cracks stories started you
know that lighthouse probably not just
in danger
dogs just like dirty dishes what are you
doing but before I go to Queen and slim
your story times oh of course you know
Thanksgiving and you have friends
givings and you have friends who hang
out and they don't call it friends
giving it's just a bunch of friends
hanging out eating Thanksgiving ish
dinner because the other group of
friends have friends give anyhow so at
the grocery store I got the cheddar Bay
biscuits the Red Lobster cheddar Bay
biscuits because I was like well you
bring biscuits to Thanksgiving ish meals
but she had her babies gifts yes anyhow
and then I left the cheese on the
counter for a couple hours and I was
like all the cheese is bad and I don't
feel like going to the grocery store cuz
I have to have this bait by tomorrow so
now I have cheddar Bay biscuits mix that
I'm probably gonna make I'm at the movie
theater it's really honest lighting like
why are there like 30 minutes of
trailers on movies these days like free
YouTube I kind of understand it more
looking back because there was no
YouTube but now there's YouTube and we
just get inundated with the trailers
when we watch videos on YouTube anyway
so just put three movie trailers on
movies man it's gotta be like a half an
hour ordeal
I can watch an episode of gargoyles what
if it's good look my hair is not always
this tall this haircut day I actually
slept in for my last haircut which I
feel bad cuz my friend opened a salon
she cuts my hair she does not give me
the friend prices she's like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you pay full price which
I'm more than happy to do because I'm
all about paying for services and
getting what you pay for
it's just my way I don't like free [ __ ]
anyhow unless it's a studio sending me
stuff how much case [ __ ] them I'll take
it but well it's you know independent
business owners and you know no pay for
your stuff but getting my hair cut and
then coming back to do a video on the
Black Widow trailer wait for it and mr.
dick a [ __ ] sitting next to Jim Gordon
rent right right
so YouTube rewind lunch today like the
last year YouTube rewind was this
completely detached soulless commercial
machine dumpster fire so this year
they're like okay we heard you and so
now we're gonna give you what you want
little clips of videos with a lot of
likes and it just it still feels
detached like YouTube is run by a robot
who doesn't know what it's like to be
human and doesn't know what human
emotion is but is trying to form that
connection but just doesn't get it you
know like it's like YouTube rewind was
made by Lieutenant Commander data before
he got the emotion ship and he doesn't
quite know what human emotion is so he's
like I have edited this year's YouTube
rewind video it features clips of many
videos with a healthy amount of likes
and healthy amount of views as well
where I could be like data it's
something else something in here you'll
get it eventually
I did YouTube's run by robots
I'm dressed up because I'm going to my
uncle pip and his husband Ryan's
Christmas party you got a dress to
impress those are the rules looking for
a health plan sucks it's such [ __ ]
it's the worst baby like Washington
healthplanfinder or a health you can go
to either one oh look at that they have
different health plans and different
companies because it's a business that's
what it is
and so and even then like my primary
care physician my doctor says he accepts
this health insurance and when they try
to send her for that they're like oh we
can't find his name so I have to call
them and ask and it's just a oh my god I
hate it hate signing up for health
insurance every year I always
procrastinate like I did so I have about
a week to do it or I have to just accept
the one that they auto-enrolled me with
which sucks and also is different than
the company I have now [ __ ] hell I
don't know if you can hear the Christmas
music can you have Christmas music
playing as I edit the Ghostbusters
trailer video it's now up now I'm about
to
the sponsorship segment that's going to
go on my Jumanji to review and I figure
I'll just review Jumanji too while I'm
at it
pet at that why not I have a cup of
coffee I might need a second one danger
you want a second cup of coffee great
alright so video when the Ghostbusters
trailer that's done and then I did the
sponsorship segment that's gonna go on
Jumanji the next level that was done
then they just did the video review for
Jumanji the next level so that's all
done it's 4:30 in the morning going to
bed get a lot of sleep that panting you
hear is danger it's just anxious energy
everywhere oh okay so I got a package
today which is it's for Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood so I got the 4k a
collector's edition they sent me to
collect danger just jumped up on the
chair now we know which dog ate my SD
card they sent me the 4k collector's
edition which looks like a book of
stories I'll open it in a second also
lunch Pam with a Rick Dalton flask and a
membership card to the fan club this is
this is actually really [ __ ] me oh
alright I give them see this is really
good
Mad Magazine I mean the movie obviously
you know what here's a digital code
whoever wants it there you go
well they even focus it there you go
thanks for watching my video
for watching my journal enjoy the free
movie or at the 45 actually I'd like
that also if you try that code and it
doesn't work that means someone was
faster than you but this is the only
place I'm giving it out so thank you for
watching so I got a copyright claim for
my Wonder Woman 1984 video and here's
the clip this is the problematic clip a
song now gal gadot returning as Wonder
Woman Steve Trevor rockin that fanny
pack and paid you a Pascale getting his
rock on that's enough for me so that's
it that was the problem there's only one
reason for it I know I'm sorry
they're minerals it's not a rock crisis
on Infinite Earths had a cameo that now
made me binge season four of Lucifer
again but I'll totally watch six
underground what does dopey one stay
here Star Wars marathon still going on
it's just on loop Empire Strikes Back
Sun right now and I was just thinking
like I love Admiral Piett he's he's got
to be my favorite of the the commanders
in the Empire it's cuz I think he's
probably a good dad you know it just
seems like a guy who's working for the
Empire doing the best job he can trying
to take down the rebels cuz he's like
nah I mean they're actually the bad guys
but I feel like when he gets home if
he's a dad he'd be like a nice dad he'd
be like a really cool dad all the other
commanders seem like dicks but he seems
really cool christmas is just creeping
up on me and I've been busy with the
videos lately it was something I've
totally forgotten to do that I need to
do
I was always do the giving tree I'm
covering it up because I don't want to
show you what the kid wants because
there's a possibility that the kid will
watch this and be like wait a minute he
got me oh my god it's Santa Claus not
real that's actually from from this
YouTube guy so incognito I'll show you
anyhow got a du skulle I'm sorry to the
mom of the kid for having to vacuum now
forever that's one of the gifts we've
got to find the other one alright so I'm
back home I had to order the other gift
on Amazon and it's supposed to arrive
Tuesday which is exactly when they leave
the mall
hope it arrives should have star wars
that day anyhow I'll make it work we'll
figure it out but I got a couple of
pretty good yields um God of War for the
Vita I like getting hard copies of me to
games cuz I love the system and it was a
29.99 game stop I know don't judge me
too harshly than the ones who had it but
if you can find God of War with the case
hard copy for 30 bucks or less it's a
good price for it I've seen it go for 30
bucks online differences it was here
right in front of me right now so if you
can find it for less than 30 bucks
snatch that up it's a good price for
also Mario Kart 7 for the 3ds on sale at
Target for 20 bucks I had Mario Kart 7
back in the day of course
traded it in for 75 cents or whatever
game stop was giving me for it at the
time but I've always wanted it back you
know I've just always wanted that game
back so hey it for 20 bucks yeah but I
mean even if I never play it which I
will but it probably won't play it too
often but I like having it so I guess
Rotten Tomatoes did a thing with Kevin
Hart in the rock where they they were
reading reviews for each other's movies
and they had to guess what movie they
were talking about and they read this
stupid fun and ridiculous but it might
[Music]
another animal hater another animal
hater whoever you are
oh my god okay first of all however how
you read that phrase it's very important
delivery is is key I'm glad to and
Johnson and Kevin Hart could see the
literary prowess of my reviews so just
settling down to edit my rights of
Skywalker review a movie I wasn't really
a fan of and then the second toy for the
the gift-giving tree that came today
I forgot I have to bring it there
because they leave them all in about
three hours so I got to go to the mall
and get that done which I showed you I
got him kinetic sand but I can't show
you the other gift because if a kid out
there gets kinetic sand and you'll be
like oh cool like I could not extend
maybe it was from that video I may or
may not have seen on YouTube but if I
show you both gifts and there's a kid
out there who gets both of these gifts
then if it is the kid didn't you'll be
able to paste it together and I was more
likely to piece it together anyway and
they'll be like oh my parents didn't
actually give me that or Santa Claus is
real and I don't want a kid to be able
to piece that together but I do need to
go to the mall let me get that done and
then when edit my rising Skywalker
review and then I'm gonna see the
bloodbath in the comment section it's
gonna be fun so I'm exporting my rides
of Skywalker review and I got this real
[ __ ] idea in the thumbnail had me
look all excited maybe have the curtain
cape lightsaber smile and pointing and
then then the review starts she's really
troll ish which I've done before I've
had like it purposely had a different
face in the thumbnail it's not been Star
Wars so I woke up to my rise of
Skywalker review being number one
trending on YouTube not just trending
but number one trending
and I thank you all for that that's
because of you without all of you
watching it and passing it around it
would not be there so thank you for that
I appreciate it I'm just tired right now
hula hoes loca it is I'm not it takes me
a while to actually wake up after I wake
up there's someone in the comments
section of my rise of Skywalker review
said Congrats on trending but I feel
like YouTube may have picked it for the
thumbnail who didn't watch the review
which I can totally see happening which
inspires me to troll more but that
that's a legit thought I can see that so
this is my frustration right here so I
have the the GC HD mark 2 week component
cables trying to play Game Boy Advance
games on this new PBM that I got and
it's splitting the screen anyhow I have
tried everything and I can't fix it so I
enjoyed the day of being on the trending
page it was funny because I was a number
one on the trending page for most of all
of the day yesterday and thank you all
for that
and then I before I went to bed I dipped
down to about 5 and now I'm not on it at
all so I went from 1 to 5 to 0 which is
strange I don't know how you go from 1
to find out how you go from 1 to 5 but
from 5 to 0 that that's weird
trending page continues to baffle but
there's a good thing than the list I
forgot I had to do a video on cats today
so I just got back from cats this cats
was not good I did it it worked you need
something called Swiss software called
Swiss put on your SD card don't you look
at how messy my room is in the
reflection I'm pretty pumped right now
so while filming my rise of Skywalker
spoiler video the lights all the all the
lights all the power in that room went
outside go down to the circuit breaker
and I flipped the breaker back on it
tripped the breaker somehow does it
again
like honey tarts giving me that weird
electrical burning smell so anyhow I did
that a couple times and then I google it
it's pretty much like don't keep
flipping the breaker back it's an
electrical fire hazard so I have to call
an electrician move everything I film to
another room probably my bedroom anyhow
I'm not even done with the video so I
figure I'll edit it and it would I have
move everything and then continue
filming what a pain in the ass so moved
it all to my bedroom and I have to call
an electrician but I got to finish this
video first a whole st. Jude commercial
just came on like a whole infomercial
it's amazing what they do but now I'm
like cry professional face
brought to you by water my friends Adam
and Morgan they went to Japan recently
and picked me up something for Christmas
which is Final Fantasy 6 for the Super
Famicom in the box and it should go on
this shelf downstairs it's big part of
me it wants to put it upstairs in my
nerd room with my Super Nintendo games
in the boxes but I feel like they should
go around here somewhere
maybe next to Marty that's good for now
[Music]
just a palate cleanser and he never came
back again because that would be weird
it's about to go to my uncle's Christmas
Eve party every Christmas Eve he has
family over and pick out and drink and
eat and it's fun family stuff but I want
to also want to do a video in uncut gems
I just saw that I feel like that can be
my last movie review before the top 10
best and worst of the year cuz in
reality at this point in the year it's
like I've seen the movies I'm gonna say
it's just so like it's it's Christmas
morning Merry Christmas still getting
over this cold it's like it's lingering
so I kind of got [ __ ] sleep last night
but heading out to my brothers where we
all meet up and for the Christmas gift
exchange Merry Christmas puppies
Christmas puppies so my top 10 best
movies of 2019 video it's exporting now
I'll get it up and it would go live at
6:00 a.m. I suspect some people will
know I think longtime longtime
subscribers longtime subscribers
longtime subscribers they get me I feel
like people who maybe haven't been with
me for as long will be like why on earth
is Shazam above the irishman which I
kind of understand you know I understand
that reaction but I can genuinely I can
look at this list look myself in the eye
and be like I agree with that list that
is your list and I can sleep at night
because it's honest so Vanessa I got me
a gift that she considered what half a
real gift half a troll gift and I
consider it 100 percent real yeah yeah
alright yeah so when everyone was in
Japan like Adam got me the Super Famicom
version of Final Fantasy 6 Vanessa got
me the mega CD version of night trap I
think I own everything I need
almost those here with these little
shits I always said if I had a cat I'd
name him alpha door also I love this
segment and again all the filming
equipment the studio stuff is still in
my bedroom because I still need to get
in contact with an electrician but I
want to thank you for the love I got on
my top 10 best and worst lists of 2019
and no they're not the most professional
lists nor are they supposed to be nor do
I ever claim they are but thank you for
the loving pretty sure right now my top
10 worst list I think it has the best
like to dislike ratio of any of my top
10 lists that'll probably change but I
feel the love this is one of the most
stress inducing scenes without doing
Chrono Trigger it's I can only compare
it to the underwater level than the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles NES game
it's just anxiety it's one of those
things if you fail you just reset the
game I think the reason this thing gives
me anxiety is because when I was younger
and I was playing Chrono Trigger and
said enter the password it's her name I
was like well where do I enter the past
I didn't understand that you had to push
the buttons the LA R and a buttons and
so I didn't know how how to enter the
name and she got her legs cut off and I
had to reset it which means I didn't
save it in between when I beat that sand
boss so I had to redo that and I just
every time I come here just gives me
sweats
well it's New Years Eve end of the
decade I don't even have anything crazy
or grand planned my friend tom is coming
over and we're hanging out that'll be
fun
I'll do it funny thing is I've waited
for a while to post on my Instagram or
somewhere of the intro to 2020 like I'm
Hugh Downs I'm Barbara Walters and this
is 2020 have the Texas says I've been
waiting years for this because I have
that I've noticed a lot of other people
are already doing it so I'm not going to
I don't want to be cliche so that's it
that's the epic conclusion of a month in
the life not just a month in the life
it's it's the conclusion of the month of
the life of the year in the life
20 19 January 2019 through December 2019
and thank you all for people who stuck
around for it no it wasn't for everybody
and I totally get that some people liked
it I just come for the movie reviews and
that's cool for people who wanted to see
a little more you know I wanted to show
you a little more because really if you
see someone's reviews online you only
know part of them like part of the life
you know a very small section of life
and I wanted to show people a little
more I didn't want didn't want you to be
like that's all we know of the guy is
the floating torso the jump cuts in the
red background and while personality can
shine through in movie reviews I like to
think I make an effort to do so still
there's there's just more and I wanted
to show that and thank you again for
sticking around and I'm getting all
nostalgic but this is this is the end of
it you know I don't really plan on doing
this in 2020 it's just something I
wanted to do for a year and I did it
maybe I'll do Instagram posts if there's
something worth like Oh that'd be like a
journal entry area Instagram video or
something but I it's already were in
February and I haven't done anything for
January but it's really there's a
missing month so I wanted to give you a
year a year glimpse of a glimpse and
actually a funny little thing I almost
forgot to tell you I came back to record
this and slip those right in here in the
thumbnail for each one of the journals
each month's journal for the font of the
month there's a color in there and that
color is the color I associate to that
month like if I think of the calendar
year just sprawled out in front of me it
starts in September and ends in August
funny enough probably because of school
when I was a kid and that calendar is a
certain color in my head the mental
calendar is and the color in the font of
the month in each month thumbnail
that's the color I associate with that
month so a little peek into my brain
anyhow I'm rambling thank you very much
for sticking around I really appreciate
it I appreciate you going on this little
year-long journey with me and we're
gonna get out of here I'll see you in
the comment sections I will see you with
the movie reviews that I will
consistently bring you or topics of
talking about trailers or whatever movie
reviews trailers and Joker things as
always we get out of here with bounce
with a puppy yet sees
[Music]
so good